Julien Gréco je voudrais bien que nous
ayons plus de temps parce que je
voudrais bien savoir un tas de choses de
vous que vous n'avez jamais dit et je
crois que il y a beaucoup de gens comme
moi je suis comme les huîtres moi il
faut m'ouvrir c'est ce que je pense il y
a chez vous un bonheur de chanter que
j'appellerai un bonheur inusable les
vagues nouvelles ou anciennes peuvent
bien passer c'est comme les cailloux
une fée que j'ai eu la chance de côtoyer
une fée qui qui me chante à l'arrêt
depuis que je suis tout petit et que
un moment la Providence a mis son mon
chemin et j'ai eu la chance de lui
écrire des chansons j'ai la chance
passer du temps avec elle j'ai eu la
chance de l'avoir telle qu'elle est
c'est-à-dire
[Musique]